c'est un sujet qui revient souvent sur
la table en France beaucoup de
professionnels de l'enfance en fait qui
veulent donner des conseils en éducation
propose cette solution dans du fil dans
ta chambre très honnêtement c'est pas un
sujet qui nous intéresse tant que ça en
fait merci
merci
d'avoir été là
autre chose
non ça va être tout merci mais je vous
jure les deux en tout cas franchement je
vous jure je suis vraiment je trouve
voilà vous êtes vous avez la classe
venez tous les deux mais je vous jure
parce que on a été dur avec vous et je
vous dis en venant déjà là c'est fini
vous avez fait vous êtes vous ne dites
voilà vous êtes vraiment des cons parce
qu'on vous a expliqué pourquoi et en
tout cas voilà on vous a regardé mais on
va vous on va vous dire pourquoi nous on
pense qu'il faut faire ça Cédric
animateur du podcast pas Patriarca
auteur du livre tu vas être papa vous
c'est comme Céline vous n'avez rien à
dire là-dessus dans la nature
Céline a raison bien sûr de préciser
comment ça s'est passé on peut pas
porter des lois on peut pas faire de
projets dedans on n'est pas ministre
j'aimerais bien j'aimerais bien avoir le
salaire aussi voilà merci Cyril mais en
fait le vrai sujet ou surtout c'est que
le ce qu'on appelle le fil dans ta
chambre ça annonce s'appelle le Time Out
en termes de pratiquer éducative en soit
c'est pas un sujet si important que ça
pourquoi parce que c'est un sujet que le
Conseil de l'Europe apporter à quelques
années tout simplement pour éviter qu'on
les enfants c'est à dire que entre file
dans ta chambre et je te mets une teinte
dans la gueule le choix est quand même
vite fait que ce soit pour signer pour
moi on a on a totalement raccord
là-dessus en revanche c'est les dérives
qu'il y a autour qui sont qui peuvent
être problématique par exemple à quel
âge on met un gamin dans sa chambre tout
seul certains préconisent 12 mois juste
parce qu'il a parlé trop fort
c'est pas possible bien sûr
on a tous en tête je sais pas si vous
regardez l'émission Super Nanny
dramatique quand même on a tous en tête
Super Nanny qui tire le gamin par le
bras qui hurle et qui va l'enferme dans
sa chambre si là vous me dites qu'il y a
pas de violence
Super Nanny
Super Nanny c'est pas
violentes de Superman est-ce que
vous-même avez des enfants tous les
jours parce que c'est un peu j'ai deux
enfants qui ont respectivement 18 ans et
bientôt 16 ans et qui t'emmerde
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est pas fil dans ta chambre c'est sort
de ta chambre ah ouais
alors quand on était en forme quand
j'étais jeune je suis en disant 160
quand on était jeune tout fonctionnait
par le système et les amis
récompenses que ce soit pour tout pour
les doutes les tâches ménagères qu'on
avait fait pour les devoirs les
résultats etc sa municipale je savais
que si je rame portait un mauvais carnet
et ben mon père allait aller sévir bon
et dans sa chambre me prouver de console
me retirer mes jeux me dire tu seras
privé de cadeaux à Noël etc et j'en
avais peur et du coup je travaillais
mais j'essaie de ramener à New York
[Applaudissements]
déjà des consoles c'est au shopping au
tennis exactement mais est-ce que les
punitions est-ce que les punitions c'est
taper pour les professeurs et on se
plaignait pas maintenant on rapporte
avec les carnets c'est le prof va
engueuler le prof en lisant pourquoi tu
as mis une mauvaise note et moi j'avais
peur de mon père j'avais pas peur du
prof moi j'avais peur des profs et de
mon père je vais répondre à ça vous
évoquez un sujet qui est extrêmement
important je vous remercie de le faire
parce qu'en fait vous vous parlez
justement du contexte socioculturel et
des mœurs qui évolue vous savez au début
du 20e siècle et ben en fait on le mari
avait droit de correction sur sa femme
il lui tapé dessus tous les jours pour
lui faire comprendre qu'ils étaient le
patron et ben les mères ces évoluent et
c'est très bien j'ai pas parlé de ça
je vous explique ce que vous devez
comprendre
aujourd'hui quand on vous dit que
quelques si on vous montre une photo
d'un homme qui frappe une femme vous
allez dire c'est de la violence
conjugale sexiste etc si on remonte
quelqu'un qui frappe une personne âgée
dans un EHPAD vous allez dire c'est de
la violence et de la maltraitance même
si on fera pas un chien vous allez dire
c'est la maltraitance et quand on frappe
un enfant on appelle ça d'éducation non
rien une base
elle est pas
conne non merci
franchement on en discute là je me dis
non on discute
on en discute
[Applaudissements]
pas laisser la finir et vous allez
demeure vous dites franchement c'est
difficile comme question
[Musique]
ils sont beaucoup dans leur chambre et
donc voilà c'est des ados sort de leur
chambre ils sont sur leur téléphone ils
sont là quand ils sont tout le temps sur
votre sur leur téléphone leur dites quoi
ces générationnel qu'est-ce qu'ils font
sur leur téléphone moi j'ai confiance en
ce qu'ils font
les limites en fait
chier dans le salon
je me rappelle je me rappelle très bien
que dans la séquence vidéo vous parliez
de l'éducation positive un peu comme ça
et moi je vais vous donner une
définition
assez simple à se rappeler c'est que
l'éducation positive le sujet c'est pas
de remettre en question la présence du
cadre donc des limites mais la violence
de cadre c'est ça le sujet c'est qu'en
fait pour faire respecter un cadre on va
plus mettre une gifle à un enfant faites
quoi alors ça va dépendre moi
personnellement
de manière assez équivante déjà
premièrement elle va réparer c'est à
dire qu'on ne va pas faire d'autres
activités donc elle n'a pas à réparer la
bêtise
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
tout simplement elle va nettoyer elle
doit avoir peur c'est tout mais pourquoi
est-ce que pour pas faire connerie
on a peur de créer un accident c'est
parce qu'on a peur de se faire choper ça
marche comme ça
chocolat chaud quand vous arrivez
et c'est vrai que qu'on soit d'accord
avec vous pas moi je vous trouve
intéressant tous les deux voilà je vous
le dis je trouve intéressant je vous
trouve un souriant je trouve qui il
défendent bien leur point de vue voilà
je le dis et je trouve que c'est très
bien que vous soyez venu ce soir après
c'est vrai que voilà Jean-Michel n'est
pas du tout d'accord c'est convictions
c'est bien sûr non mais vous euh
c'est-à-dire vous vous Cédric disait il
y a un instant pour punir son enfant il
faut le faire réparer euh voilà et
Céline a plutôt confiance elle fait ouh
c'est plutôt vous êtes vous avez
confiance le dialogue le dialogue la
confiance
ils étaient plus petits
vous avez de la chance vous êtes tombé
sur des enfants équilibrés famille qui
va alors c'est peut-être celle qui a
fait que
par rapport à votre ville
l'environnement tout mais il y a des il
y a des enfants moi j'ai des potes ils
ont des trois enfants je pense à un pote
là trois enfants c'est des diables il y
a 3 ans il y a 6 ans il y a 11 ans si
vous leur dites répart ta connerie comme
ça il réparera jamais et au-delà des
mots parce qu'il y a des conneries mais
les mots quand ils veulent pas quand il
veulent pas venir à table ils veulent
pas s'asseoir c'est des diables
qu'est-ce que vous faites si vous voulez
si vous leur dites pas un cadre en
disant valant ta chambre ou je te punis
je parle pas de fessée parce que fais-tu
je suis contre comment on fait sur un
enfant qui est rebelle parce que il y a
beaucoup d'enfants qui ont des problèmes
qui sont rebelles avec les parents et
qui pourrissent la vie des parents
comment vous faites vous y allez parle
encore quand vous allez faire alors déjà
dans un premier temps je serai rappeler
une chose très importante c'est que le
fil dans ta chambre donc le timer encore
une fois c'est quelque chose qui visait
à supprimer les violences physiques et
les insultes auprès des enfants c'est
pour ça comment on fait pour lui mais
déjà on parle du principe qu'on punit un
enfant ça c'est quoi le c'est quoi la
définition de la punition sociale alors
moi dans mon fils quand je le punis euh
bah je lui donne ma voiture il va faire
des tours autour de la maison
[Applaudissements]
et du coup j'ai posé une question simple
donc tu as arrêté non déjà que
l'efficacités
en justement d'instant le respect et non
la peur non mais moi j'aimerais qu'on
soit dans vraiment dans les cas
pratiques
votre fiche pas il a 10-12 ans 13 ans 9
ans 8 ans il fait une énorme bêtise vous
vous faites quoi Jean-Michel si il fait
des langues ça veut dire voilà il sait
pas il
voilà il provoque il a volé votre
voiture il fait un accident derrière on
a déjà fait des conneries bah ça a été
une punition immédiate je vais prier en
vacances avec nous en vacances il est
resté à Paris voilà travailler alors je
sais pas s'il a travaillé exactement en
tout cas il est pas parti en vacances
avec nous il a été privé comme ça il
était prévu de vacances voilà on est
resté sur trois semaines en Espagne il
est
c'est terrible encore une fois vous êtes
un homme extraordinaire mais peut-être
un mauvais père
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ma fille en 5e année de médecine donc je
pense qu'elle a été bien éduqué elle est
très contente de ce qu'elle fait et
cetera
[Applaudissements]
il a 8 ans et il est en agrégé de
médecine
[Applaudissements]
vas-y
oui le traumatisme que vous infligez à
un enfant par la punition de ne pas
partir en vacances tu connais mes
enfants
j'imagine les enfants extraordinaires
ce que vous avez fait vous avez de la
chance que vos enfants ne vous en ai pas
voulu de ne pas eu toi tu fais quoi
Gilles quand ta fille elle fait une
grosse bêtise je discute avec elle mais
c'est vrai
Mélanie Mélanie
on ne tape pas un enfant depuis plus
d'un enfant
[Musique]
merci pour le soutien sur ce la
punitions
néanmoins enfin dire à quelqu'un qu'il a
un mauvais père mauvaise mère de mauvais
parents c'est pas possible c'est pas
possible et souvent et je vais vous dire
quelque chose on peut regarder
l'éducation qu'on donne aux parents moi
j'ai connu le martinet la gifle plein
plein de choses
vous Cédric vous avez l'air franchement
moi je signe hein franchement c'est vrai
non mais vraiment Cédric parce que donc
vous étiez juste
l'éducation
grec classique de l'époque néanmoins je
suis pas là pour juger mes parents moi
mes parents j'estime qu'ils ont fait de
leur mieux avec ce qu'ils avaient comme
contexte de culture à l'époque et avec
les habitudes que tu as de l'époque vous
voyez je renvoie pas du tout j'aime bien
Cédric parle bien on peut avoir
10 à 3 ans
je vais l'emmener chez des familles
d'enfants turbulents on va voir si juste
parce que justement il y a les missions
Pascal le grand frère je crois qu'il y a
des enfants juste en lisant il faut que
tu respectes
que je fais ça pourquoi est-ce qu'on
doit apprendre une question
mielleux tout à fait inopportun vous
savez la fermeté ça peut ça peut se
faire par plein d'autres choses que les
cris et l'écran
93 vous voyez ça c'est facile
tu vas réparer il y a pas de citoyens
c'est quelque chose
son petit frère c'est quoi vous allez
faire quoi si elle vous parle mal
pourquoi parce qu'elle voudrait pas
manger parce qu'il y a des enfants voilà
moi j'ai un enfant de 4 ans et un de 7
ans et et c'est pas aussi facile que ça
je pense que vous vivez vraiment dans le
monde de oui ça ne se passe pas comme ça
c'est pas vrai c'est c'est on ne peut
pas quand un enfant refuse de manger ou
en bête ça son frère quand il fait ses
devoirs etc à un moment il faut éloigner
l'enfant qui qui pose problème
je suis d'accord avec vous je suis
d'accord avec vous il faut éloigner
l'enfant s'éloigner traumatisent leurs
enfants
[Applaudissements]
ou la délinquance est de plus en plus
jeune et malheureusement je pense que
c'est dû à au laxisme et à ce genre de
métal qui a pas forcément parce que sur
des bonnes intentions en fait tous les
jeunes en fait qui que vous voyez qui
ont enfin voilà les délinquants c'est
pas forcément des gens qui viennent de
famille privilégiée ou la bienveillance
fait partie du cadre familial
alors il y a pas si longtemps on avait
encore le SHIELD de 7% des parents qui
étaient voilà qui disait mettre des
fessées alors vous m'avez pas dit les
deux Cédric vous l'avez pas dit les deux
ce que vous faites pour voilà bon pour
calmer ici vous vous disputez et il y a
pas de punition jamais de punition
jamais tu vas être privé de console tu
vas exprimer téléphone
en fait voilà est-ce que vous avez déjà
privé les enfants de téléphone jamais
non rien
d'accord pardon je suis vraiment
d'accord avec vous et je vous soutiens
personnellement
personnellement je n'ai jamais été puni
par mes parents et
pourquoi pourquoi parce que au départ
j'ai eu un cadre mais pas un cadre trop
étriqué parce que toutes mes copines qui
avaient un cadre bête et méchant et bah
au final elles ont fait des conneries de
ouf moi mon cadre était très large je
peux faire tout ce que je voulais
j'étais responsable dans mon cadre mes
parents me faisaient confiance et ils
avaient l'autorité naturelle sur moi et
c'est ça qui est positif et je pense que
de leur dire fil dans ta chambre ça veut
dire par rentrer on coupe la
conversation ça ça va pas je pense qu'il
faut être dans la communication parce
que si
on en voit seul dans ma chambre je crée
ma colère mais j'ai dans ta chambre et
pour ceux qui connaissent
[Musique]
psychologiques je suis sûr qu'un enfant
à qui on dit tout le temps film dans ta
chambre il va avoir la blessure de
l'abandon et la blessure de lui bien sûr
de se prendre
[Applaudissements]